nous venons de vivre une situation
inédite
je pense qu'avec la reprise le
déconfinement les usagers de la route
feront preuve de sagesse de discipline
de respect vis-à-vis des uns et des
autres et que les états d'esprit vont
changer car la route ne pardonne pas les
mauvais conducteurs
ça a toujours été un bon temps des
difficultés sur la route sinon les morts
ne fait pas de cadeau quand on est
mauvais conducteurs en tant que moniteur
auto école
comment allez vous procéder je préconise
la visière pour le moniteur dans la
voiture à la place du masque parce que
porter un masque de 6 heures du matin
jusqu'à midi et de 14 heures jusqu'à 18h
ça devient infernal
quand l'élève arrive à l'auto-école
poppers en cours
avant de retirer la voiture l'élève doit
mettre son masque
mais trop c'est qu'en suivant les cas et
se laver les mains avec le gel ensuite
étant à l'intérieur de la voiture qui
est déjà désinfecter le volant le vide
vitesse le ferai à mr la voiture doit
être déjà prête pour accueillir les
lèvres je préconise le port de la
visière à la place du masque pour les
moniteurs qui doivent cependant se laver
aussi des mers entre chaque candidat
doit se laver les mains
le candidat aussi droit sur le nouveau
candidat doit se laver les mains avec le
gel et
ça ne peut être qu'une bonne chose